but in terms of being on stage leaves
you've done lots of stand-up and you've
done those tours but you have we just
run one play I'm gonna play griff with
Griff Griff Rhys Jones called the miser
in the West End which oh there I am
looking yes I have to ask your question
be honest would would you freeze-frame
and Matt's ready you decided to be see
it yeah it's hard and it being a player
I didn't realize this and it's to shows
their day on some days and I thought I'm
gonna look after meself so I stopped
eating sugar for about three weeks four
weeks before and I was really strict
about it and then on the first couple of
shows I was really craving it and I went
to a health shop and they had a bag of
sweets that had no sugar in them I
thought this is my dream come true I
know what's good you know what's coming
now yeah I didn't know what was coming
so I have one or two if you haven't
eaten sweets six weeks and unlike me
you're obsessed with them I at the lot I
get 40 to 50 of these little sweets
some of you know what's happening today
so I go on stage and I'm committing
eeping off stage and I'm on an awful lot
No
so rumblin feeling a real rumble you
know I won't get too graphic but let's
just say I went to the toilet and it
went out a lot quicker than it came out
right it started coming back again so I
look at the packet mean it must be this
and on the back it says do not eat more
than one or two of these at a time
because they are a laxative
I've eaten 40 of these
a lot right so he's bad enough the
situation but it's made worse by the
fact that in the middle of the show I
had to turn round and show my backside
to the audience that was the gag I turn
round the audience laughs and there it
is right and I'm thinking I'm terrified
I'm terrified anyway but at least with a
costume on if an accident happens you're
off all right
imagine that front row and I'm literally
going every few minutes soon as I go up
I'm in the toilet and this scene is
about five ten minutes long and I said
to the costume woman I said I had to
tell her so I'm really nervous about
this because I've been going to the good
old it she said don't really if worse
comes to worse I'll put a tampon up
there and I said no if worse comes to
worse I'll be
sure that would have because that
wouldn't just come out like a missile
[Laughter]
[Music]
you